>>> WHEN IT COMES TO COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS HOW MUCH OF A ROLE
SHOULD RACE PLAY?
THAT QUESTION BACK IT'S IN NEWS
THIS WEEK.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HARVARD
UNIVERSITY'S HISTORY, THE
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS ACCEPTED
INTO THE INCOMING FRESHMAN CLASS
IDENTIFY AS NONWHITE.
58.8% TO BE PRECISE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME CAME NEWS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
IS INVESTIGATING ALLEGATIONS THE
SCHOOL IS DENYING PLACES TO
QUALIFIED ASIAN-AMERICAN
STUDENTS.
NOW, THE HEAD OF ADMISSIONS
CONSULTANT AT INTERVIEW S.O.S.
HAS AN UNIQUE EXPERIENCE WITH
THIS TOPIC.
AN INDIAN AMERICAN, HE REALIZED
THE ONLY WAY HE WOULD BE
ACCEPTED AT MED SCHOOL WOULD BE
TO PASS AS BLACK.
HE CHRONICLED HIS EXPERIENCE IN
HIS BOOK "ALMOST BLACK.
THE TRUE STORY OF HOW I GOT INTO
MEDICAL SCHOOL BY PRETENDING TO
BE BLACK."
HE JOINS ME NOW.
SO, YOU WERE STUDYING STATISTICS
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO,
AND YOU SAY TO YOURSELF, I DON'T
STAND A CHANCE WITH MY 3.2, WHAT
DID YOU DO?
>> WELL, I SHAVED MY HEAD, I
TRIMMED MY EYELASHES AND I
DECIDED TO JOIN THE ORGANIZATION
OF BLACK STUDENTS SO I COULD
APPLY TO THE MEDICAL SCHOOL AS A
BLACK MAN.
I ALSO USED MY MIDDLE NAME JOJO.
I SUBSEQUENTLY INTERVIEWED AT
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
MANAGED TO GET WAIT-LISTED AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON AND
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA, THEN
RANKED THE THIRD AND FOURTH BEST
MEDICAL SCHOOLS IN THE COUNTRY
AND GOT INTO ST. LOUIS SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE DESPITE THE FACT THAT
MY PITIFUL 3.1 GPA WAS
DRAMATICALLY LOWER THAN THEIR
AVERAGE OF 3.7.
NOW, I WANTED TO MENTION A
STATISTIC YOU MENTIONED EARLIER
IN THE PROGRAM WHICH IS THE
MAJORITY OF HARVARD IS NOW A
MINORITY.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S TRUE.
I THINK THAT'S VERY DECEPTIVE
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE
FORGETTING ABOUT THE P POCAHONT
FACTOR.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHITER THAN
WINTER IN ALASKA, BASED ON
FLIMSY REASONS, AS A RESULT, IT
SKEWS THE STATISTICS BECAUSE
THEY KNOW IT CAN IMPROVE THEIR
CHANCE OF ADMISSIONS.
SO SELF-REPORTING ON MINORITY, I
DON'T THINK THAT'S NECESSARILY
THE BEST DATA TO USE.
>> SO, VIJAY, WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
YOU DIDN'T JUST CHECK A BOX.
YOU WENT FULL-ON TOOTSIE.
>> YEAH.
>> AND THERE MAY BE OTHERS WHO
MAY NOT PER SONIFY A GROUP?
>> I HAVE SO MANY, THEY'RE GREAT
GREAT GRANDMOTHER WAS HIPPS, FOR
FLIMSY REASONS THEY CALL
THEMSELVES MINORITY BECAUSE THEY
KNOW IT'S GOING TO IMPROVE THEIR
CHANCE FOR ADMISSIONS.
WE CANNOT IGNORE THE POCAHONTAS
FACTOR WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
STATISTIC, THAT 51% OF PEOPLE AT
HARVARD ARE SAYING --
>> WELL, LISTEN, BECAUSE YOU ARE
USING THE NICKNAME, LET'S GO
THERE.
YOU SAID THAT WHAT LINCOLN DID
VIS-A-VIS SLAVERY, TRUMP WILL DO
VIS-A-VIS AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
EXPLAIN.
>> I BELIEVE THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP, BY APPOINTING
CONSERVATIVE ANTI-AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION JUSTICES AND BY USING THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO GO AFTER
THE COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES, I
BELIEVE HE WILL END AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION LIKE LINCOLN ENDED
SLAVERY.
AS YOU KNOW, BOB JONES
UNIVERSITY, MANY YEARS AGO, LOST
ITS NONPROFIT STATUS BECAUSE OF
ITS RACIST POLICIES.
SIMILARLY, WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ISSUE OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, THE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES HAVE
PLEADED GUILTY AS CHARGED.
THEY PUBLICLY ENDORSED RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IN THE FORM OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IN THE FISHER
CASE.
THEREFORE, THE TRUMP JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT COULD USE, WITH THE
SUPREME COURT, COULD EFFECTIVELY
FORCE THE UNIVERSITIES TO END
THEIR RACIST AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
POLICIES.
BY FORCING THEM TO LOSE THEIR
FEDERAL FUNDING.
SO, AS I SAID, PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL END AFFIRMATIVE ACTION LIKE
LINCOLN ENDED SLAVERY.
>> AND I WANT TO PUT ON THE
SCREEN A PIE CHART THAT SHOWS
THE BREAKDOWN OF THIS INCOMING
CLASS AT HARVARD.
I WANT TO ASK YOU A QUESTION.
22.2% ASIAN-AMERICAN.
HOW MANY ASIANS ARE TOO MANY
ASIANS FOR THE HARVARD INCOMING
CLASS?
SHOULD THERE BE ANY LIMIT WHAT
SO FAR?
WHAT IF ON THE MERITS IF YOU GO
BY GPA AND S.A.T. SCORE YOU
COULD FILL THE ENTIRE CLASS AT
HARVARD WITH ASIAN-AMERICANS,
SHOULD THEY DO SO?
>> FIRST OF ALL THERE A
MULTIFACT TOMORROW PROCESS, NINE
CRITERIA INCLUDING GRADES AND
ESSAY.
I'M NOT SAYING GRADES AND
TERRITORIES SHOULD BE THE ONLY
THING.
BUT THE SIMPLE POINT IS AS AN
ASIAN-AMERICAN, IT IS HARDER TO
GET INTO COLLEGE OR GRADUATE
SCHOOL THAN ANY OTHER RACIAL
CATEGORY.
IN EVERY PLACE WHERE THE DATA IS
AVAILABLE, IT IS CONSISTENTLY
HARDER FOR AN ASIAN-AMERICAN TO
GET IN.
I USED THE EXAMPLE EARLIER OF
MEDICAL SCHOOLS, ADMISSIONS
WHERE IT WAS 50% EASIER TO GET
INTO MEDICAL SCHOOL AS AN
ASIAN-AMERICAN COMPARED TO AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
STATISTICAL DATA, THERE'S NO
ACTION FOR RACISM.
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IS A
SYSTEMIZED RACISM.
IT'S A RACIAL CLASSIFICATION
SYSTEM THAT CHANGES PEOPLES
CHANCE OF ADMISSION TO COLLEGE
OR GRADUATE SCHOOL.
AND THERE'S NO JUSTIFICATION FOR
RACE
RACISM.
>> BUT VIJAY, YOU UNDERSTAND THE
POINT I'M TRYING TO MAKE FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
ADMISSIONS THEY ARE SEEKING TO
ASSEMBLE A DIVERSE STUDENT BODY.
AND IF ASIANS ON THE MERITS
COULD DOMINATE THE CLASS, THEY
MIGHT NOT WANT TO DO THAT,
BECAUSE THAT, THEREFORE,
DETRACTS FROM THE ABILITY OF
HAVING EQUAL REPRESENTATIONCH
ALL OF
ALL GROUPS.
YOU GOT THE FINAL WORD.
>> I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP THAT,
I'M PROUD TO HAVE GONE TO UCLA
WHICH IS A SCHOOL THAT DOESN'T
PRACTICE THOSE ADMISSIONS.
WE HAD A RICH EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE WITHOUT PRACTICING
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION IN THE
FORM OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
SO I DON'T WANT ANYONE TO
BELIEVE THAT AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
RACISM IS ESSENTIAL TO A GOOD
EDUCATION.